et installez-vous voilà on va on va
essuyer on va on va appeler l'assistant
plateau qui va venir essuyer ça tout de
suite on est en direct je vous présente
en attendant bonjour Mathias wargon
merci beaucoup d'être notre invité chef
du service des urgences et du SMUR du
centre hospitalier de La Fontaine à
Saint-Denis en Seine-Saint-Denis on a
évidemment beaucoup de sujets à voir
avec vous mais d'abord cette triple
épidémie qui touche le pays covid donc
vite grippe est-ce qu'on se prépare à
entrer dans l'hiver le plus difficile
jamais vécu à l'hôpital j'espère que non
mais oui en fait mais on y est déjà pour
la bronchiolite je pense que les
urgences pédiatriques ont eu l'hiver le
plus difficile déjà alors que ça faisait
déjà plusieurs années qu'on avait cette
problématique de bronchiolite avec des
transferts d'enfants d'une région à
l'autre avec des urgences pédiatriques
complètement débordées et quand on
regarde les courbes en réalité on a fait
une bronchiolite énorme par rapport aux
hivers précédents et en plus un peu en
avance donc c'est pas seulement une
question de précocité il y avait aussi
beaucoup plus plus d'enfants malades oui
est-ce que tous les enfants ont pu être
soignés parce que le gouvernement nous
dit non il n'y a pas eu de tri tous les
enfants ont été soignés oui les enfants
graves normalement ils ont été soignés
pas toujours dans de bonnes conditions
chez nous à l'hôpital de Saint-Denis il
y en a qui ont été pris en charge dans
des chambres alors qu'ils auraient dû
être pris en unité de soins continus les
patients de réanimation qui ont été pris
en unité de soins de continuer enfin on
a fait un peu du bricolage des couloirs
des
urgences enfin des choses visibles ou
nous on est habitués aux urgences
adultes mais où ils sont pas habitués
aux urgences pédiatriques et juste
raison et donc on espère que que ces
enfants là tous ces enfants là ont pu
être pris en charge maintenant du tri
aux urgences on en fait tout le temps
quand le ministre dit qu'on fait pas de
tri bon il sait très bien de quoi on
parle puisqu'il est urgentiste lui-même
bien sûr qu'on fait du tri et bien sûr
que quand on a énormément de monde on a
une petite tendance à renvoyer des
patients et il est elle est là la
problématique c'est renvoyé des patients
des urgences c'est pas un problème
beaucoup de gens viennent aux urgences
alors qu'ils pourraient être mieux
traiter en ville le problème c'est où
est-ce qu'il manque de médecin de ville
parce qu'on n'a pas de réseau en ville
parce qu'on n'a pas on n'a pas été
moderne et qu'on a pas trouvé de
solutions avant d'être dans le mur au
manque de médecin de vie enfin les
médecins de ville moi je le sais depuis
que j'ai fait mes études de médecine les
études de médecine je les ai commencé en
1985 ou 86 donc on sait très bien qu'on
va manquer de médecin et on n'a pas
anticipé du tout mais est-ce que le tri
faire un tri aux urgences faire un tri
en amont je veux dire pour éviter que
les gens aillent aux urgences est-ce que
ça c'est opérationnel alors ça a été
dans certaines villes mais encore une
fois faire un trip pour éviter que les
patients aillent aux urgences c'est pas
mal c'est aspect dans plein de pays dans
les pays nordiques et leur espérance de
vie est pas différente de la nôtre la
différence c'est où est-ce qu'on les
réoriente vers qui on les réoriente
alors on peut les réorienter vers des
médecins et quand même il y a de la
place chez certains médecins et puis on
peut les réorienter vers d'autres
professions et on a mis énormément de
temps à se décider il y a une grosse
résistance des médecins
les médecins eux-mêmes qui voulaient pas
qu'on réoriente vers des infirmières ce
qu'on appelle des infirmières de
pratiques avancées mais pour l'instant
il y en a quasiment pas des infirmières
de pratiques avancées on les a
sélectionnés pour s'occuper de maladies
chroniques c'est très bien mais il faut
aussi qu'elle puisse s'occuper de
maladie aiguë et puis on a aussi les
kinés par exemple qui pourraient prendre
ça en charge on a vu que les pharmaciens
savaient vexiné vacciner c'est quand
même pas le geste du siècle donc on peut
se répartir la charge on peut on a eu la
téléconsultation moi je suis à titre
personnel je pense pas que ça soit la
solution en aiguë en tout cas ça
remplace pas les urgences mais sur
certaines pathologies chroniques ça peut
aider enfin voilà il y a toutes mes on a
attendu d'être dans le mur pour faire
quelque chose à l'heure actuelle quelle
est la situation dans les services des
urgences dans votre catastrophique chez
moi c'est là je vais aller dans mon
service en sortant d'ici je sais déjà
que je vais avoir des patients en
attente d'hospitalisation depuis hier
soir puisque hier soir à 18h je n'avais
déjà quasiment plus de place dans
l'hôpital donc je le sais très bien que
je vais avoir ces patients en attente
d'hospitalisation comme tous les matins
comme tous les hivers comme tous les
matins depuis depuis une quinzaine
d'années donc c'est à dire concrètement
avec des patients dans des brancards sur
des coups bien sûr des couloir pas dans
mon service mais parce qu'en fait très
attention à ça mais sur des brancards
bien sûr et mal surveillé puisque je
n'ai le personnel que pour accueillir
des urgences la ce matin je sais que
j'aurais un deuxième une deuxième unité
d'hospitalisation or et moi et tous les
autres services d'urgence et donc on
sait très bien que ça existe encore une
fois il y a des années le syndicat SAMU
urgence de France avait fait un concours
qui s'appelait le No bed challenge c'est
à dire qu'on comptait les nombre de
patients qu'on avait dans nos lits dans
nos brancards le matin c'était à
l'époque c'était il y a 4-5 ans donc
avec quelles conséquence est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui il y a des gens qui
meurent aux urgences de soins et parce
que vous faut arrêter cette histoire
c'est ce qui a essayé de lancer le même
syndicat et c'est idiot non la
problématique elle est pas de mourir le
jour même la problématique elle est un
de mourir à 30 jours il y a une étude
qui va être à nouveau lancée mais aussi
d'avoir de moins bonnes conditions de
rester plus longtemps à l'hôpital ça ça
a été prouvé et éventuellement quand on
est une personne âgée de décompenser et
peut-être de jamais rentrer à la maison
alors qu'on aurait pu passer une nuit
sur un brancard dans un service
d'urgence on a des personnes âgées qui
rentrent parfaitement autonome et
consciente qui en sorte grabataire
pour éviter cette situation en tout cas
pour éviter qu'elle empire le
gouvernement Elizabeth borne Emmanuel
Macron va avoir les images appel à la
responsabilité et appelle apporter le
masque le chef de l'État hier est apparu
masqué pour donner l'exemple dit-il
est-ce que ça t'appelle à la
responsabilité ça suffit regardez les
images lui et ministre sont masqués
personne d'autre ne l'est voilà c'est
tout c'est de la com c'est de la com
on sait très bien que ça ne marche pas
et ils veulent on a décidé de plus
emmerder les gens avec le masque ça veut
dire quoi c'est un manque de courage
politique pour vous ouais moi je pense
que c'est un manque de courage politique
oui les gens ne veulent plus du masque
on le voit bien on voit comment on se
fait insulter parfois par certains
sénateurs on est sur Public Sénat moi
j'ai été insulté par des anciens
sénateurs et des sénateurs il y a une
sénatrice récemment qui voulait qu'on
mette du goudron et des plumes alors
comme elle était lâche elle a dit il
faudrait que ça soit ses collègues qui
lui mettent du goudron et des plumes oui
oui très bien une sénatrice LR mais deux
sénateurs LR qui sont à la charge sur
avec les du vague anti masque bien sûr
mais qui sont encore sénateurs bien sûr
vous pouvez donner leur nom ou alors il
y en a une c'est Madame goy Chavant je
crois l'autre c'est monsieur houppert
qui a été et qui vous dit quoi et Ben
qui qui sont du côté de François de tous
les complotistes et qui soutiennent ces
mouvements antimasque et antivax et un
autre Pozzo di Borgo pareil moi j'ai
interpellé Gérard Larcher sur Twitter je
n'ai évidemment eu aucune réponse par
contre quand le sénateur ou perd se fait
condamner par le conseil de l'ordre des
médecins là on appelle à la liberté
d'expression moi ma liberté d'expression
quand je parle du masque quand je parle
du vaccin elle est largement mise en
cause par ces mêmes personnes et par
tous ceux qui les suivent donc je crois
je peux l'éthique pour vous oui
il ne fait pas aujourd'hui son travail
de ministre de la santé mais je sais pas
s'il fait ou pas son travail mais on est
moi j'ai un peu l'impression qu'on est
reculons dans cette histoire là tout le
monde sait qu'à un moment il va falloir
faire normal que l'hôpital va mal parce
que depuis des années on lui demande de
faire des choses qu'il ne doit pas faire
aux urgences moi je reçois du social
mais quand je demande des lits on parle
tous des lits on dirait il va falloir
rajouter des lits à l'hôpital non il va
falloir avoir des soins de suite moi ma
problématique c'est pas les patients qui
sont dans l'hôpital c'est le fait qu'ils
ne puisse pas rentrer chez eux qui ne
puissent pas sortir vers d'autres
structures parce que c'est cher parce
qu'on les accepte pas hier j'ai appris
que les EHPAD de Seine-Saint-Denis ont
maintenant on peut aller dans les EHPAD
rapidement on a un mois c'est une mesure
qui a été faite par Braun d'ailleurs et
bien c'est 20 euros par jour et bien
n'osez pas elles sont remplies de
patients parisiens pas de patients de
Seine-Saint-Denis et donc les patients
sortent pas l'hôpital et comme ils
sortent pas les autres rentrent pas sur
la vaccination est-ce que vous portez le
même constat parce qu'on voit que la
vaccination sur la quatrième dose ça
marche pas très bien la vaccination
contre la grippe ça marche pas très bien
est-ce que vous dites là aussi le
gouvernement n'en fait pas assez non
est-ce que vous avez vu quelque chose de
clair sur la vaccination moi j'ai rien
vu de Claire même nous on sait pas
exactement qui on doit vacciner
donc voilà donc moi je suis vacciné
contre la grippe et contre et contre le
covid avec le nouveau vaccin mais c'est
vrai que c'est pas très clair que de
toute façon on a des problématiques de
vaccination de la population générale et
du personnel soignant depuis au moins 20
ans le covid n'a fait que mettre en
lumière ces problématiques
sur la réintégration des soignants non
vacciné là aussi il y a un débats c'est
un gadget dans le débat c'est un gadget
on sait très bien que c'est moins de 1%
des personnes voire moins de 0
mais est-ce que c'est 1% il faut les
réintégrer mais il faut probablement les
réintégrer moi je ne crois pas mais leur
proposer quelque chose oui c'est clair
on peut pas laisser des gens sans être
payé pendant deux ans c'est pas possible
mais qu'est-ce qu'il faut clarifier que
les populistes s'en servent mais on sait
très bien que ça soit la proposition de
loi et les filles ou c'est les FN en
réalité on sait très bien qu'avec les
allers-retours entre l'Assemblée et le
Sénat ces gens là même si on remettait
on les remettait ça serait des mois et
puis on a expliqué que il fallait leur
faire une PCR tous les matins donc ils
vont venir à l'hôpital on va leur faire
une PCR avec le prix que ça coûte et
puis après on va attendre deux heures
parce que c'est le minimum pour avoir le
résultat de la PCR enfin tout ça c'est
pour clarifier la situation est-ce qu'il
faut les licencier mais probablement que
c'est ce qu'il faut faire oui avoir une
situation claire vis-à-vis de leur dire
ce en être et puis leur permettre de se
réinsérer autrement dans la société oui
tout à fait vous pouvez vous permettre
au moment où vous manquez de personnes
encore une fois bon d'abord on sait même
pas combien on en manque mais si on
prend le les 5000 ou 6000 soignants
soignant parce que là-dedans il y avait
des secrétaires il y avait il y avait
autre chose 6000 soignants on a 10 à
12000 établissements hospitaliers ethpad
bon ben voilà c'est à dire que on va 0,5
personnes par établissement ou même une
personne par établissement ça ne va
strictement rien changer ce qu'il faut
changer c'est les conditions de travail
de façon à ce qu'on puisse embaucher des
gens et d'ailleurs on a bien vu ce que
ce que fait le ministre ces données de
l'argent pour que ça continue de
fonctionner à chaque fois on l'a fait
cet été on l'a fait cet hiver et à
chaque fois après on perd la on perd des
gens donc il sait bien une question
d'argent et sur l'argent parce que c'est
vrai qu'il y a des enveloppes alors il y
a une Ségure de la santé là il y a à
nouveau des envies dans le budget est-ce
que c'est le bon calibrage
et et si je peux lui donner du doliprane
on va prendre les mêmes le ministre il
aime bien les les comparaisons je
connais bien je vais qu'on soit très
clair je connais bien depuis des années
il est urgentiste mais on va quand on
donne du doliprane à quelqu'un qui a une
pneumonie on fait baisser la fièvre on
soigne pas la pneumonie donc là on donne
du doliprane c'est du doliprane très
très cher mais on donne du doliprane à
un moment il va falloir soigner
l'hôpital soigner l'hôpital c'est le
recentrer sur ses actes mais est-ce que
c'est de l'argent utile parce que c'est
vrai que ça c'est utile on centaine de
millions d'euros est-ce que c'est utile
pour vous parce que ça permet de garder
les gens en ce moment mais le problème
c'est que il y a même c'est pas pérenne
les mesures Braun elles étaient valables
jusqu'en septembre elles ont été
reconduites mais c'est reconduit il y a
pas d'horizon et on va voir avec le CNR
mais c'est pas évident que vous en
attendez de ce conseil
CNR les gens qui étaient là c'était
vachement sympa il y a eu plein d'idées
mais en fait c'est les mêmes que je
connais habituellement qui sont qui vont
voir la RS qui vont c'est les mêmes en
fait donc on n'a pas besoin c'est des
représentants syndicaux c'est des gens
qui sont impliqués dans l'organisation
donc tout ça
on aurait pu le faire avant on va parler
justement on va continuer à parler de
cette situation aux urgence on va
revenir quelques mois en arrière au
début quasi tout début de la crise covid
on était même au coeur de cette crise de
documentariste Éric Guéret a filmé les
premiers pas d'un terme dans votre
service on va regarder un extrait de ce
documentaire où on vous voit justement
face aux difficultés du manque de
personnel
donc c'est difficile de la sortir oh
[__] la les psychiatres faut arrêter
il faut nous laisser un peu travailler
là
c'est pas possible non je confirme donc
tant pis on fait de la médecine dégradée
on n'a pas le choix
[Musique]
c'est vraiment la merde
mais mon problème là maintenant c'est
que j'ai le personnel qui est au bord du
craquage
et il me faut il faut au moins une
infirmière et une aide-soignante plus au
moins une aide-soignante en plus au
moins au moins
pour maintenant est-ce que j'ai des
petits déj à donner j'ai des patients à
ranger j'en ai partout là partout
partout
j'en ai partout il me faut du personnel
en plus là je peux pas tenir avec ce que
j'ai comme personnel
je trouve que je suis plutôt de bonne
humeur par rapport à la situation
mais mais si déjà on me soulageait de la
psy 9 9 il y en a que 5 ou 6 à
hospitaliser hein
[Musique]
la débandade
d'hospitalisation
tous les jours pareil
c'était entre novembre 21 dans une heure
c'est pire parce que c'est pire d'abord
le covid ça permet de resserrer les gens
alors là on est quand même dans la
deuxième vague déjà ça commence à
déliter mais ça a permis de resserrer
les gens mais parce que à ce moment là
pendant le covid on faisait ce pourquoi
on a été formé ce pourquoi on était payé
c'est à dire voir des patients graves
aux urgences et puis les hospitalisés
c'est pas moi qui cherchais là on est
dans la deuxième vague dans la première
vague on ne cherchait pas les lits on
avait des cellules au niveau régional
qui nous cherchait les lits avec hélas
des médecins qui des chirurgiens qui
travaillaient pas donc c'est pour nous
ont beaucoup aidé mais là c'est terminé
et donc non seulement vous même c'était
là c'était un cas exceptionnel où tous
les matins vous appeliez
hier matin et c'est ce matin je vais
faire ça et ou si c'est pas moi c'est
quelqu'un d'autre de mon service et donc
oui c'est ce que je vais faire mais dans
il y a pas de lit ailleurs et donc on va
faire la même chose je vais m'engueuler
avec les étages parce qu'ils vont pas
vouloir me prendre des patients lourds
pourquoi ils veulent pas me pardon des
patients lourds parce que c'est une
grosse charge de travail pour leur
personnel qui s'en va parfois ils sont
des lits fermés parce que il y a pas de
personnes l'hélie fermé c'est pas parce
que le gouvernement ou je sais pas qui
veut fermer ou lopit ou le sèche le
directeur veut fermer les lits c'est
parce que il y a personne pourra être
l'hélice ça veut rien dire c'est du
personnel et puis et puis pourquoi il
veut pas vouloir me prendre de personnes
âgées parce que les personnes âgées une
fois qu'elles sont dans les lits bah
c'est ce que je disais au début on peut
pas les sortir vers des soins de suite
on peut pas les faire rentrer à la
maison parce que c'est extrêmement
complexe le maintien à domicile que on
n'a jamais mis les investissements
nécessaires que il y a pas de médecins
de ville pour faire des visites c'est
terminé et que ben voilà et que ces
patients là on a pas de solution sinon
les paddes ils veulent pas forcément y
aller et on comprend pourquoi et donc on
est coincé et ça c'est ma vie tout à
l'heure ça veut dire que ce qu'on
pensait être que nous on a découvert
comme une situation de crise au moment
du covid en fait c'est devenu non ça
l'était avant la situation elle était
avant le covid il a tout fait déborder
mais il y a eu une grève des urgences en
2019 moi j'ai un blog depuis le les
années 2007 ou 2008 quand je relis ce
que j'écris mais c'est la même chose en
fait moi quand je relis mon blog je me
pose une question c'est qu'est-ce que je
fous encore là vous êtes découragé
parfois vous avez envie d'abandonner ah
oui oui tout à fait il y a des jours on
se dit bon ah non on va y aller et tout
ça et on essaye de faire autre chose
hier soir par exemple après avoir
longuement discuté avec deux directeurs
de l'hôpital pour dire demain matin ça
va être la merde on a fait un staff en
visio sur de la neurologie c'était
intéressant mais quand même oui il y a
des jours on se dit mais oui je vais
enfin pourquoi je me lève le matin je
vais passer une mauvaise journée je vais
pas faire de médecine et puis je vais
rentrer chez moi après avoir fait une
mauvaise journée mes médecins ils vont
pas faire de médecine ils vont passer
leur journée au téléphone je me dis
finalement je devrais faire autre chose
me lever correctement le matin passer du
temps à la machine à café au self
rentrer à la maison descente et une fois
que je suis rentré à la maison puis
m'occuper de ce qui se passe à l'hôpital
oui qu'est-ce qui vous fait tenir
qu'est-ce qui vous donne envie malgré
tout de vous lever le matin et de
continuer à aller au soir parce que je
ne sais pas faire autre chose c'est
quand même une des vraies solutions
maintenant je suis un peu âgé peut-être
que je serai plus jeune je partirai et
puis ce qui me fait tenir c'est quand
même le service public oui c'est le
service public oui être à Saint-Denis
c'est plus important encore qu'ailleurs
mais le service public c'est quelque
chose de très important est-ce que vous
ne faites pas que des urgences vous
faites aussi du social ce que vous
disiez oui mais pas que ça mais
justement j'ai pas envie de faire du
social moi je suis médecin ce que
j'apporte en Seine-Saint-Denis de façon
extrêmement prétentieuse c'est de la
médecine d'excellence en
Seine-Saint-Denis et la médecine du
service public ça doit être de la
médecine d'excellence voilà c'est ça
qu'on doit faire et elle doit être
partout dans le territoire pas seulement
à Paris pas seulement à la PHP mais
aussi dans des centres hospitaliers
publics comme celui de Saint-Denis et
oui je crois qu'on apporte de la bonne
médecine à Saint-Denis et c'est
important vous ne le disiez si il était
jeune je réfléchirai je réfléchirai
peut-être autrement est-ce que vous êtes
inquiet pour l'avenir de votre métier
est-ce que vous pensez que demain on
aura encore suffisamment de médecins
alors demain on en aura pas ça c'est sûr
j'en suis pas sûr et là on voit bien que
après avoir pourri intégralement quand
même la médecine en France les
politiques et là c'est tout le monde un
faut arrêter ça fait 30 ans que ça dure
continue à pourrir la vie des médecins
là on a vu cette histoire de d'interne
avec les déserts médicaux alors les
déserts médicaux en fait il y a eu aussi
le moment où il y a eu beaucoup de
médecins et on s'est habitué au fait
qu'il y avait beaucoup de médecins et
trop de médecins à ce moment-là quand
même puisque je vais pas suffisamment
bien et là d'un seul coup on décide de
les envoyer et on se retrouve quand même
avec un humérus clausus ou un humérus
apertise pas très grand où on a des
médecins qui ont passé ce concours très
difficile et à qui on dit à la dernière
année tu vas aller faire on est un peu
comme Mao on va les envoyer à la
campagne ceux qu'on raté le concours qui
était peut-être très bon j'en sais rien
mais qui ont raté le concours qui sont
partis à l'étranger eux ils vont pas
retrouver à faire à être obligé de faire
ça et leur diplôme il est valable dans
toute l'Europe donc on marche un peu sur
la tête quoi et est-ce que on a proposé
à ces médecins là de bien les payer pour
aller à la campagne mais pas il y a la
campagne parce que c'est la campagne
qu'on pense mais pas du tout on leur a
dit vous allez être faire une année
supplémentaire de pseudo interne alors
vous n'êtes pas un terme parce que vous
avez passé votre test donc vous êtes
docteur en médecine mais on va vous
payer mal pour aller faire ce que
personne d'autre ne veut faire et
d'ailleurs on a bien vu que aucun vieux
médecin a dit ah oui moi je vais y aller
et puis finalement les syndicats de
médecins généralistes ont pas dit non
plus ça ils se sont élevés mais les
enseignants voulaient de toute façon
cette quatrième année donc voilà donc ça
se fait au dépend des jeunes c'est pas
c'est pas en emmerdant les gens qu'on va
les aider et c'est pas eux qui vont
repeupler nos campagnes ils sont déjà
mariés mais c'est tout ça c'est de la
grosse démagogie c'est de la démagogie
c'est du pansement sur une jambe de bois
c'est-à-dire qu'à aucun moment on pense
réformer le système aucun moment on va
expliquer aux gens que plus jamais ils
n'auront de médecin parce que la
médecine ça ne marche pas comme ça c'est
comme les petits hôpitaux faire croire
qu'on va avoir des petits hôpitaux ça ne
marche pas c'est pas des bons systèmes
les petits hôpitaux voilà c'est la
médecine du 21e siècle un mot sur deux
autres sujets qui concernent évidemment
l'hôpital d'abord les cyberattaques
puisque le centre hospitalier de
Versailles a été la cible d'une cyberata
qu'il n'est pas le premier est-ce que
l'hôpital est vulnérable aujourd'hui
l'informatique hospitalière est nulle et
on le sait tous très bien les logiciels
qu'on utilise sont pas du participe à
notre mauvaise qualité de vie participe
à ça on a tous tous les centres
hospitaliers ont de gros problèmes
d'investissement en informatique
d'investissement en équipe on n'a pas
d'argent pour avoir des équipes
suffisamment importantes et peut-être je
connais pas le niveau moi j'ai pas de
problème avec globalement les
informaticiens à l'hôpital sauf qu'ils
sont pas assez et nous on a par exemple
hier après-midi on s'entraînait à la
prochaine cyberattaque hier matin
puisque notre informatique était en
panne non non on fait pas d'entraînement
régulièrement et que je le dis quand ça
marche pas bah on peut pas être attaqué
ça c'est une bonne protection quand ça
marche pas du tout on n'est pas attaqué
et on s'entraîne régulièrement oui la
semaine dernière on était en papier mais
pas parce que à cause d'une cybera
attaque parce que le serveur était down
donc voilà donc il y a pas que moi c'est
dans tous les hôpitaux que ça arrive et
l'autre sujet c'est la fin de vie
puisque la convention citoyenne sur la
fin de vie des buts aujourd'hui ce sont
à peu près 60-75 pardon citoyen tirés au
sort qui vont plancher pendant 4 mois
est-ce que pour vous il faut une
nouvelle loi alors qu'on a déjà plus de
20 départements qui n'ont même pas accès
aux soins palliatifs
la problématique des soins un peu
aléatitifs est très importantes moi en
tant qu'urgentiste j'ai des patients qui
meurent avec des morts plus ou moins
attendues pas des morts subit mais soit
des patients de maladies chroniques en
fin de vie soit des patients âgés en fin
de vie qui au lieu de mourir en général
à l'Ehpad ou chez eux meurent chez nous
et donc c'est un problème que nous on
rencontre mais très fréquemment on a
énormément de gens qui meurent alors pas
aux urgences sur un brancard dans un lit
dans autre unité d'hospitalisation mais
c'est quelque chose de très fréquent
face auquel on est confronté je pense
que c'est une question extrêmement
importante très difficile qui va donner
lieu à des débats à mon avis très
démagogiques il y avait un article dans
Le Monde récemment de quelqu'un des
Pays-Bas d'un médecin des Pays-Bas qui
était pour qui avait un article
extrêmement mesuré très intéressant ça
va participer au débat mais chacun doit
y réfléchir et on doit avoir des mesures
anticipées mais enfin des des lois pour
vous la loi classe néonetti est
suffisante la loi classe néonetti elle
est extrêmement hypocrite voilà bah
parce que on sait tous très bien que
quand on met de la morphine et de
l'hypnovel alors là je vais entendre
tous les médecins de soins palliatif me
dire que c'est pas vrai mais on sait
très bien c'est d'une certaine façon
c'est vrai ça dépend le dosage et donc
on sait très bien alors on tue pas les
patients mais on est on est dans un
entre deux on dit on leur donne quand
même on les soulage on les tue pas et
c'est vrai que moi j'ai des patients qui
peuvent durer des jours avant de mourir
et donc on ne les tue pas mais on est
dans un entre deux très compliqué donc
il faut clarifier oui mais il faut pas
le faire très vite je parle la loi ou
pas je pense par la loup ah oui il faut
protéger les professionnels de santé il
va falloir aussi que on fasse pas comme
dans l'avortement c'est à dire des
histoires de moi j'ai pas j'ai pas envie
de le faire ou des choses comme ça il
faut il faut normer les choses de façon
à ce que ça soit facile pour tout le
monde que la loi elle décide ou pas le
Tanasi actif parce que c'est comme ça
que ça s'appelle ça s'appelle de
l'euthanasie active moi à titre
personnel je n'ai pas d'opinion enfin ça
dépend des jours ça dépend des gens
c'est très con je pense que c'est
vraiment quelque chose de très compliqué
et que il faut que chacun réfléchisse à
ce qu'il a envie mais on peut changer
d'avis et c'est bien que ce soit des
citoyens qui réfléchissent à ça
il faut qu'il y ait des soignants mais
des citoyens la différence entre les
soignants et les citoyens c'est que nous
on a une on sait ce que c'est et des
morts on en voit on sait ce que c'est
que mourir et c'est pas quelque chose de
romantique
merci Mathias merci beaucoup d'avoir été
notre invité ce matin et de nous avoir
accordé cet entretien on passe tout de
suite au club des territoires